Transcriber: Ecem Yagci
Gözden geçirme: Esra Çakmak
Yapay zekâ, robotlar ve hukuk.
Bu konuda yaklaşık 6 yıl önce
çalışmaya başladım.
Okudum, yazdım,
uluslararası ve ulusal konferanslarda
çalışmalarımı paylaştım,
farklı alanlardan gelip bu konuda çalışan
insanlarla bir araya geldim,
fikir alışverişi yaptım.
Adeta kendi kendime ikinci bir doktora
tasarladım denilebilir.
Sunumlarımın birinin ardından alanında
oldukça yetkin bir hukuk profesörü
hocamız dedi ki:
“Başak Hanım çalışmanız güzel.
Hedefiniz ne?”
O an içimdeki ses
şöyle fısıldıyordu zihnimde:
“Dünyayı değiştirmek.”
Ama bu yanıtı vermeye utandım
ve daha alçakgönüllü amaçlarımdan
bazılarını paylaşmakla yetindim.
“Bu konuda özellikle ülkemizde bir
farkındalık yaratmak ve yapılacak hukuki
çalışmalara destek vermek.”
Bu yanıtı vermemin üzerinden
yaklaşık 4 yıl geçti
ve ben bugün çocukluğumdan beri gördüğüm
dünyayı kurtarma rüyalarına daha sıkı
sarılmam gerektiğini anlıyorum.
Oysa başlangıçta her şey kişisel
merak ve zevk içindi.
Çocukluğumdan beri bilim, teknoloji ve
sosyal meseleler konusunda okumayı
ve hayaller kurmayı çok seviyordum.
Sonrasındaysa hepimizin hayatını
etkilediği için ve dinamik bir alan
olduğu için hukuk seçmeye karar verdim.
Ama bilime, teknolojiye, sanata ve diğer
alanlara olan ilgim hiç kaybolmadı.
Bugün burada olmamın nedeni
de işte o merak duygusu.
Çalışmaya başladıktan, bu konuda, yaklaşık
bir yıl kadar sonra Avrupa Birliği
Parlamentosu bir öneride bulundu.
Dediler ki: “Hukukta biliyorsunuzdur
iki tür kişilik var.
Gerçek kişiler, tüzel kişiler.
Hadi dediler, robotlara elektronik
bir hukuki kişilik verelim.
Yol açtıkları zararlardan da
kendileri sorumlu olsun.”
“Aa ne güzel!” diye düşündüm önce.
Ama o zamanki bilgimin sınırlı oluşu
henüz ve aşırı iyimser önyargım
beni adeta duvara toslattı.
Robotların ancak mitolojideki ejderler
kadar kendi eylemlerinin sonucunda
olabilecek varlıklar olduğunu
anladım öğrendikçe.
Örneğin Türk mitolojisinde yağmuru gök
ejderinin yağdırdığına inanılır.
İşte mesela bir otonom aracın yol açtığı
zarardan dolayı kendisinin sorumlu
olabilmesi ancak bu kadar
gerçek olabilirmiş.
Bunu anladığımda bir kez
daha duvara tosladım.
Bu teknolojiyi geliştirenler, kullananlar
ve kullanımlarının reel, hukuki, hatta
politik sonuçlarından etkilenenler var.
Yani fail de mağdur da insanlar.
Fail, mağdur.
Peki, yok mu bu teknolojide
hiç olumlu bir taraf?
Hep olumsuzluklardan konuşuyoruz.
Olmaz mı? Saymakla bitmez.
Örneğin arama kurtarma çalışmalarında
canlıların enkazdan
çok daha çabuk kurtarılmasında,
kanser gibi hastalıkların
erken teşhisinde,
tarımda dijitalleşmenin hızlandırılarak
hepimizin karnının doyurulmasında
bu teknolojiden faydalanılabilir.
Hatta bu konuda pek çok çalışma
çoktan başladı bile.
Öte yandan,
dünyamızın belki de en büyük sorunu olan
eşitsizliğin daha kalıcı hâle gelmesinde
ve bu teknolojinin ham maddesi olan veriyi
elinde tutan büyük aktörlerin
dünyayı canlarının istediği gibi
şekillendirmesinde de kullanılabilir.
Yapay zekâ bizi gelecekte ele geçirir mi?
Yapay zekâyı kontrol edenler
bizi ele geçirdi mi?
Sanılanın aksine bu muhteşem teknoloji
yarından değil,
bugün hepimizin hayatını
etkilemeye başladı bile.
Şimdi düşünelim.
Yok mu bu teknolojinin acaba hiç faydası
dediğimizde aslında hukukun bize vermesi
gereken pek çok şey var.
Şimdi tarihte, insanlık boyunca, hep tarih
boyunca pek çok kişinin aklına hep
gelmiştir yapay zekâ fikri
ama bugüne doğru en somut adımlar
Alan Turing tarafından atıldı.
Peki yapay zekâ neyle gelişir?
Makineler nasıl öğrenir,
verilerden.
Veriler nasıl ortaya çıkar?
Bizden.
Yani, gözetleniyor muyuz?
Pek çoğumuzun aklına bu sorudan sonra
George Orwell’in 1984 romanı
ve oradaki Büyük Birader gelir.
Bense daha çok Aldous Huxley’nin
“Cesur Yeni Dünya”sındaki
kehanetin gerçekleşme riski
olduğunu düşünenlerdenim.
1984′ün aksine “Cesur Yeni Dünya”da
o kadar çok yasak yok.
Bilgi de orada bir yerde.
Ama insanlar öyle yetiştiriliyorlar
ki artık bilgiyi istemez,
merak etmez ve sorgulamaz hâle geliyorlar.
Biz bugün kendi zihinlerimizi
giderek tek tip beslerken,
makinelere olabildiğince çeşitte
veri aktarıyoruz.
Tıpkı kendi ellerimizle bir yandan dünyayı
çoraklaştırırken, bir yandan da
şimdilik cansız olan Mars toprağını
yeşertmeyi planladığımız gibi.
Mars’ı adeta başka bir yer değil de
öz yuvamızmış hâline getirmeyi
planladığımız gibi makineleri de bir gün
bizi kendilerini insan olduklarına ikna
edecek ve hatta bizi aşacak bir
noktaya getirmeyi planlıyoruz.
Aman bunlar olmasın diyenlerdenseniz,
belki de kaygınızın nedeni bu teknolojinin
kendisi değil de cansızı canlı,
akılsızı akıllı hâle getirmeye muktedir
zihinlerimizi ne yazık ki birbirimizi ve
gezegenimizi yok etmekte de gayet iyi
kullanıyor oluşumuzdur.
İşte o zihinlerin ortak ve iyi için
kullanılmasına yönelik
kurallara ihtiyacımız var.
Ama adil kurallara.
Harry Potter romanındaki ruh emicilerin
yaptığı gibi bedenlerimizden zihnimizin
derinliklerine dek görünmeyenler
tarafından adeta makinenin içine
aktarıldık.
Bir yandan bunun farkında olanlar var.
Mesela benim kızım gibi.
Geçen yıl online ödenen Siber Güvenlik ve
Hukuk dersime kapı arkasından kulak
misafiri olup daha sonra
dersten sonra bana
“Anne, sipariş verdiğimiz
şirket mi hacklendi?” diyen,
ben “Evet” dedikten sonraysa
“Verilerim gitti!” diyen kızım.
Evet, kızım geçen yıl 6 yaşındaydı
ve bu yıl da olduğu gibi verinin
ve verinin öneminin farkında.
Bir yandan da
tüm hayatını sosyal medyaya
aktaranlarımız var
ama bizim burada “Bu yanlış yapıyor,
bu iyi değil, bu doğru değil”
demeye ayıracak, bununla vakit kaybedecek,
hatalara odaklanacak bir zamanımız yok.
Hukuka ihtiyacımız var.
Ama öyle bir hukuka ki sadece zarar
olduğunda ortaya çıkıp onun telafisine
yönelik kuralları bize sunacak
bir hukuk sistemine değil.
Zarar ortaya çıkmadan önce “Acaba bu
zararın doğmasını nasıl engelleyebiliriz?”
sorusuna cevap verecek bir hukuk
sistemine ihtiyacımız var.
Bunu biraz somutlaştıralım.
Bir apartman düşünün.
Apartmanın her katında ortak alanlarda
“Yangın çıkarsa camı kırın ve zile basın.”
yazılı uyarı düğmeleri olsun.
İşte telafi edici hukuk
biraz buna benziyor.
Ama düşünün ki aynı apartmanda bu
uyarılara rağmen her dairede 3 yaşında
çocuklar var ve onların erişebilecekleri
noktalarda da kibritler var.
İşte hukuk önleyici bir mekanizma kurarak
o çocuğun eline kibrit geçmesini de
önleyebilmeli.
Yapay zekâ konusunda hukuk, telafiye
odaklanabilir ama ondan çok daha önemlisi
önleyici kurallar koyabilmesidir.
Şimdi senaryoyu biraz değiştirelim.
Hani dedik ya yarından değil, bugünden
bu teknoloji hayatımızı
etkilemeye başladı diye.
Bakalım gerçek hayatta bu nasıl oluyor?
Son yazdığım kitap, işyerlerinde
kullanılan yapay zekâ
sistemlerine ilişkindi.
Biz aslında mesleklerin daha önce
dönüşmesini ve otomatikleşmesini beklerken
iş yerindeki yönetim
otomatikleşmeye başladı.
Mesela Türkiye’de de şirketlerin yaklaşık
%15′i öyle ya da böyle insan
kaynaklarında yapay zekâ sistemlerini
kullanmakta.
Şimdi hamile olduğunuzu varsayalım ve
diyelim ki e-ticaret sitelerinden 7-8 ay
sonrası için alışveriş yapıyorsunuz.
Bir yandan da iş arayışındasınız.
Bildiğiniz gibi pek çoğumuzun aslında
bizim dijital ortamdaki pek çok verimiz
aynı zamanda bizimle ilgili belirli
çıkarımlar yapılabilmesi için
kullanılmakta ve aynı zamanda veri bir
ticari değer olarak alınıp satılmakta.
Şimdi biz herhangi bir yerde hamile
olduğumuzu belirtmemiş dahi olsak,
e-ticaret sitelerindeki verilerimizin
insan kaynakları şirketlerine satıldığını
düşündüğümüzde, o zaman biz belki pek çok
iş ilanını hiç görmüyor olabiliriz.
Gördüklerimizin pek çoğundan da neden
olduğunu anlayamadığımız bir şekilde
eleniyor olabiliriz.
Aslında dünyanın pek çok ülkesinde ve
bizim ülkemizde işe alımda hamilelik veya
cinsiyet nedeniyle ayrımcılık hukuken
yaptırımlara tabi kılınmış
ve düzenlenmiş durumda.
Ama işte bu konuda zurnanın
zırt dediği nokta şurası:
Biz eğer dünyanın en güzel kanunlarının
yazılı olduğu ülkede dahi olsak,
bu kanunlardan faydalanma hakkımızın
doğduğunu fark etmezsek,
bu kuralların ne anlamı kalır?
Biz hamile olduğumuz için belli bir
ilanı görmediğimizi belki asla
fark edemeyeceğiz.
Diyelim ki bir şekilde bu nedenle
ayrımcılığa uğradığımızı fark ettik.
Bu durumda da bunun bir uyuşmazlığa
dönüşmesi hâlinde
ispat etmemiz bu teknik süreci
oldukça güç.
İşverenler açısından düşündüğümüzde,
başka şirketlerden tedarik ettikleri
yapay zekâ sistemlerinin bu kez onlar
işe alımda ayrımcılık yaratmadığını
ispat etmekte oldukça zorlanacaklar.
Peki ne yapmalı?
“Hukuk hep teknolojinin peşinden
koşar ve asla yetişemez” denir.
Evet, biz sadece telafi edici bir
hukuktan bahsediyorsak,
hukuk asla teknolojiye yetişemeyecek.
Ama “zararın ortaya çıkmasını en baştan
nasıl engelleriz?” sorusu
bütün oyunu değiştirebilir.
Özellikle bazı alanlarda kullanılacak
yapay zekâ sistemlerinin ancak belli
denetimlerden sonra kullanılmaya
başlamasına yönelik kurallar koyabiliriz.
Veya insanların mahremiyetine saygılı
yapay zekâ sistemi geliştiren şirketlerin
ürün ve hizmetlerinin kullanımını belirli
kurallarla teşvik edebiliriz.
Biz insanlar da önyargı dediğimizde ve
teknoloji konusunda karamsar senaryoları
kucaklamakta aslında oldukça iyiyiz.
Fakat bu karamsar senaryoların da
oldukça iyi bir tarafı olabilir.
İkinci Dünya Savaşı sırasında yazar Stefan
Zweig büyük bir karamsarlığa kapıldığı
hâlde şunu yazmıştı:
“Karanlık da ışığın bir çocuğudur.”
Bizden alınan verilerle bizimle ilgili
kararlar alınmasında kullanılan yapay
zekâ sistemlerinde aslında
muhteşem bir şey saklı.
O zaman bu sistemin aksaklıklarını
düzeltme gücüne de biz sahip olabiliriz.
Gelin bunu gerçek bir olayla biraz
aklımızda netleştirelim.
COVID-19 sırasında pek çok ülkede olduğu
gibi Birleşik Krallık’ta Britanya’da da
yüz yüze eğitime ara verilmişti ve hatta
lise öğrencilerinin üniversiteye
girişlerine etki edebilecek
sınavlardan biri iptal edilmişti.
Bunun yerine dediler ki “Öğretmenler
öğrencilerin geçtiğimiz yıllardaki başarı
notlarına göre bir hesaplama yapsın.”
Sonra bundan da vazgeçtiler.
“Haydi bunu daha net, daha tarafsız
ve daha çabuk yapalım
bir algoritmik sistem kullanalım.”
Fakat sonucunda şöyle bir şey oldu.
Tercih edilen sistem aslında başarı
performansından ziyade öğrencilerin
ikametgah verilerine odaklandı ve bu
verilerden yola çıkarak bir çıktı yarattı
ve sonuçta yoksul ve göçmen mahallelerde
oturan öğrencilerin notları, refah
seviyesi daha yüksek mahallelerden gelen
öğrencilerden bariz bir şekilde daha
düşük çıktı.
Bu o kadar keskin bir farklılıktı ki
hemen tespit edildi ve verilen ilk
tepkiye ülkenin Milli Eğitim
Bakanının cevabı şu oldu:
“Biz yapmadık, algoritma yaptı.”
İşte.
Eğer dersek ki “Bırakalım, bu teknolojiyi
canının istediği kişi canının istediği
yerde ve canının istediği şekilde
uygulasın ve hiçbir kurala gerek yok.”
Her birimiz, her alanda hep
bu cevapla karşılaşacağız
en büyük sorundan,
en küçük probleme kadar:
“Ben yapmadım, algoritma yaptı.”
Fakat bu olayın devamı bize
çok güzel bir şey daha söylüyor.
Bakalım ne oldu?
Tahmin edeceğiniz gibi bu yanıt büyük
bir öfke patlamasına yol açtı.
Öğrenciler aldılar ellerine pankartları,
düştüler Londra sokaklarına
ve o pankartlarda yazanlar aslında
gençlerin ne kadar her şeyin
farkında olduğunu gösteriyordu.
Şu yazılıydı genelde:  “Bu algoritma falan
değil ya, bu düpedüz elitizm.”
Tepkiler büyüdü.
Öğretmenler ve veliler de gençlere destek
oldu ve ülkenin bakanı geri adım attı.
Algoritmik sonuç iptal edildi.
İşte bu olayın bize
gösterdiği ikinci şey şu:
Eğer farkında olursak ve birlikte olursak,
bu teknolojiyi geliştirenleri,
kullananları ve kanun koruyucuları
daha iyisini yapmaya teşvik edebiliriz.
Yapay zekâdan korkuyor musunuz?
Kendinize bakın.
Yapay zekâya hayran mısınız?
“Si monumentum requiris, circumspice.”
Bu Latince deyişin anlamı şu
“Eğer onun için yapılmış
bir anıt arıyorsan çevrene bak.”
Bu deyiş, Londra’daki pek çok eserin
olduğu gibi St. Paul Katedrali’nin de
mimarı olan Sir Christopher Wren’in
aynı katedral içindeki mezarına
oğlu tarafından yazdırılmıştı.
Bu büyük mimar için özel süslü
bir anıta gerek yok.
Baş yapıtın içindesin.
Çevrene bak.
Peki Christopher Wren, bu katedrali kimden
esinlenerek tasarlamıştı?
Mimar Sinan’dan.
Mimar Sinan için de, onu
görmek ve anlamak için de özel bir anıta
ihtiyacımız yok.
Kendi sözleriyle ustalık eserim dediği
Selimiye Camii’ne gidip
çevremize bakmamız yeterli.
Yapay zekâ sizsiniz, biziz.
Hayranlık duyduğumuz da, korktuğumuz da
aslında kendi zihinlerimiz.
Çünkü yapay zekâ o zihinlerden yaratılıyor
ve ne şekilde dünyamızı
değiştireceği de tamamen bize
ve nasıl kurallarla
rotasını belirleyeceğimize bağlı.
Yapay zekâyla dönüşen bu dünya
artık başka bir yer.
Bu başka yerin mimarı kim olsun?